mein name ist christina seehofer und der
zeit der kompaniekommandant der erste
mit der polizei company ich sage immer
frau die hauptsächlich männer führt ja
zu dir passt hauptband und gar vor allzu
schlecht der erste gedanke praktisch war
überlegt habe jetzt geht es um
bundesheer und der zweite gedanke war
dann zu mir selbst sagen
christina das ist auch so ist das jetzt
hier und das machst du nicht und genau
dann habe ich wieder weg sagt viele
konflikte sprechen mich selbst
eigentlich wenn du immer in deinem leben
sagen wir es da das musst du sowieso und
das ich hoffe so sollten wir sie nie
coole sachen erreichen und dann haben
gesagt hat das mach jetzt ich glaube
dass männer und frauen anders auf diese
situationen reagieren vielleicht anders
führen anders arbeiten aber ich glaube
dass das was positives ist es ist meiner
männer völlig egal welche sexuelle
reagieren da ist welche religion woher
du kommst wer du bist immer so sie
trauen das zu leben was man sich ja
angepasst an die soldatischen tugenden
an umfasst heute dazu geraten beruf aber
trotzdem dass man selbst bleibt
[Musik]
mein privatleben natürlich gibt es schon
einige wenn die das hatte was ich machte
das sagt uns was machst du dir ein
bundesheer irgendwie im büro tätig oder
die vorzimmerdame von jemandem wichtigen
beim bundesheer und wenn dann hat
erklärt was sie macht das ist selber als
soldat bin eher das kann man natürlich
erhofft nicht so glaubt aber im
endeffekt dann aber wundert
die bis 1990 geboren und hans georg
kreisler vorkrisenzeit jahr an den
grenzen und mein motor hat sie sich
selbst gesagt um zu den praktischen
neugeborenen kinder gleichzeitig gott
sei dank
bist du ein mädchen weil dann wirst du
zum bundesheer und das bleibt der sport
aufgehört aber sie sagt dass server
spannend dass man das nicht wünscht aber
dass man dann eigentlich sich das eigene
kind oder die tochter wird genau in dem
so glücklich und zufrieden